[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag bonjour à
tous bienvenue sur sensation en
association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec Lina Méziane élève en
première bac pro boulanger-pâtissier au
lycée hôtelier de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines bonjour
bonjour Vous participez au concours
national du meilleur croissant au beurre
Sainte-Mère AOP grâce à votre victoire
lors de des sélections régionales
commencent s'est déroulée justement
cette journée d'épreuve alors tout
d'abord nous sommes arrivés aux
alentours de 9h pour un petit un petit
déjeuner pour accueillir tout le monde
ensuite on a eu l'épreuve justement qui
a duré deux heures durant laquelle on
devait effectuer tous les tourages avec
nos pâtes et le beurre justement le
beurre d'ini AOP et ensuite on avait une
petite pause déjeuner donc au cours de
laquelle on est allé au restaurant et on
est revenu pour enfin justement durant
cette pause déjeuner on avait tous les
croissants qui étaient en train de
pousser donc ce qu'on appelle l'après
donc ils étaient dans un appel ça une
panematique c'est c'est une chambre où
les croissants poussent et donc ensuite
en venant de du déjeuner on devait les
mettre à cuire au four et ensuite une
fois que tous nos croissants étaient
cuits on les présentait sur notre tour
et on était dans une salle à part on
voyait pas le jury et le jury venait
donc c'était complètement anonyme avec
des numéros donc on n'avait pas les noms
ni l'école rien du tout et le jury
venait venait délibérer justement
sur des critères bien précis et ensuite
bah on avait un petit peu de clôture
durant lequel les résultats étaient
annoncés et comment est-ce que vous avez
connu justement ce concours alors moi
c'est vrai que l'année dernière donc
dans ma dur ma première année mon
professeur de travaux pratiques mais on
a beaucoup parlé il savait que j'étais
intéressé par tout ça donc doc il m'en
avait parlé et ça m'avait directement
plu donc j'attendais l'année d'après
pour pour m'y inscrire alors le
croissant c'est un savoir-faire bien
français une viennoiserie très souvent
aimée par les Français mais aussi à
l'étranger je pense qu'il nous est tous
arrivé de tomber sur un croissant moins
bon que les autres justement pour vous
quel est le secret essentiel pour
préparer un bon croissant pour préparer
un bon croissant je dirais la
température de la pâte faut qu'elle soit
vraiment bien froide ça permet d'avoir
un travail qui va être plus agréable et
une pâte qui aura des meilleures
qualités donc la température qu'elle
soit vraiment bien froide et puis être
précis ne pas abîmer le feuilletage
aussi c'est très important pour avoir
pour avoir un beau feuilletage bien
croquant avec une belle texture le goût
mais aussi l'aspect du Croissant compte
lors de ce lors de ce concours oui
exactement alors il faut savoir qu'on
est on est noté on a des critères
d'évaluation et dans ces critères là il
y a le volume le volume l'aspect la
coloration le feuilletage mais l'aspect
visuel du feuilletage aussi avant le
goût on a plusieurs critères qui qui
s'intéressent justement à l'esthétique
du Croissant vous êtes également triple
championne de France de de karaté donc
vous avez presque l'habitude finalement
des concours et des compétitions est-ce
que malgré tout il y avait une
appréhension peut-être différente par
rapport à vos à vos concours à vos
championnats de karaté je dirais pas une
appréhension différente parce que ça
reste une compétition
la pression elle est elle est quand même
là concours de pâtisserie ou de karaté
c'est la même chose mais c'est vrai que
c'est pas les mêmes on a on n'a pas une
pression pour les mêmes choses on va
dire là on a des facteurs surtout qui
peuvent pas forcément se contrôler comme
la température du laboratoire les fours
on peut voilà il y a des choses qu'on
contre pas forcément donc c'est c'est
une pression différente mais tout aussi
là stressé justement face à la à la
finale nationale les 9 et 10 mai
prochain comment est-ce que vous vous
préparez justement cette à cette
dernière étape beaucoup d'entraînements
je pense que c'est vraiment le secret
l'entraînement à l'entraînement
voilà je me je m'entraîne énormément
pour pour vous préparer oui justement
d'ailleurs je remercie mais je remercie
mes coachs mes profs de travaux
pratiques pour leur disponibilité
monsieur le cornet qui est Monsieur
Vendée qui qui m'accompagne et qui
m'accompagne et qui sont qui sont
présents avec moi et qui m'aident
énormément dans les 9 et 10 mai
qu'est-ce qui va se passer comment ça va
s'organiser ce cette finale alors il
faut savoir que la finale elle se
déroule en deux jours donc le 9
justement on arrive et on a deux heures
il me semble pour préparer nos pâtes
donc on a on a les pâtes qui qu'on doit
faire la veille ensuite on a le
lendemain on va faire justement tout ce
qui est tourage dès le matin et on peut
venir avec nos garnitures déjà préparées
donc celle-ci elles seront faites en
amont et ensuite on va commencer le
tourage et un peu le comme le même
procédé que que pour la sélection
régionale donc vous devrez donc
confectionner 12 croissants au beurre du
ciné Sainte-Mère AOP et une viennoiserie
revisitée selon un thème imposé ce que
vous avez l'habitude notamment à travers
votre formation de revisiter des
viennoiseries ou des pâtisseries alors
c'est vrai que en pâtisserie on est
enfin moi je suis troisième année donc
on travaille encore les bases et on
travaille tout enfin on les travaille de
manière ordinaire mais c'est vrai que
nos profs ils essayent au maximum qu'on
essaye de de d'innover que ce soit par
la décoration finale ou ou de créer
quelques petites choses revisiter par la
force par la forme l'esthétique donc oui
après c'est vrai que là c'est c'est
autre chose c'est pas vraiment le même
procédé
et vous soutiennent pour pour ce
concours et ce qu'ils auront la
possibilité notamment de venir vous
soutenir le le jour de la finale alors
oui il y aura mes parents qui vont se
rendre sur place avec moi qui
m'accompagneront pour pour les résultats
et bah c'est vrai que ma famille m'aide
énormément que ce soit pour me donner
plein d'idées pour vraiment y mettre
beaucoup c'est un réel soutien au
quotidien mes proches mes parents mes
frères je remercie aussi mais mon club
de karaté qui participe énormément à ce
pour que ce soit tout simplement c'est
intéressant en proposant des idées mais
aussi tout le monde entourage mes
copines qui goûtent et qui me donnent
leur avis ce qui est très important pour
moi donc oui je suis bien entourée la
pâtisserie ça fait partie de vos
objectifs de toute façon après vos
études c'est votre projet professionnel
c'est vrai que j'ai toujours voulu faire
de la pâtisserie ça a toujours été le
métier que je voulais faire le métier de
mes rêves donc oui je compte pas arrêter
tout de suite donc ça serait quoi ça
serait ouvrir votre boulangerie
finalement être alors parce qu'on a des
pâtissiers créateurs aussi pâtissière
créatrices aussi est-ce que vous ça
serait plus ça ou ça serait une
boulangerie ouvrez votre propre commerce
alors c'est vrai que pour le début
j'aimerais continuer les études un
minimum donc j'aimerais
entamer une mention complémentaire en
chocolat puis par la suite en dessert à
l'assiette me spécialiser dans tout ce
que je peux et ensuite bien plus tard si
je peux ouvrir ma propre pâtisserie ce
serait cool je serai là pour goûter on
dit souvent que la pâtisserie c'est
aussi un art certain artisan pâtissier
revisite les recettes mais aussi
l'aspect visuel de certaines pâtisseries
est-ce que c'est aussi votre objectif
plus tard de de revisiter oui c'est vrai
que j'aimerais apporter ma petite touche
Lina à la pâtisserie française si c'est
possible je vais tout faire pour en tout
cas d'apporter ma personnalité et ma
touche dans la pâtisserie française
la cuisine même la pâtisserie et les
viennoiseries c'est de l'art de toute
façon je pense qu'il y a une part il y a
une part d'art dans tout ça donc je suis
d'accord mais qu'est-ce que vous aimez
dans dans la pâtisserie qu'est-ce qui
vous qu'est-ce qui vous anime dans la
pâtisserie est-ce que c'est justement
cette revisite ou est-ce que c'est va
faire des recettes un petit pique etc
déjà je pense que la pâtisserie ça ça me
va enfin ça va aussi avec mon caractère
le fait d'être pointu vraiment de d'être
dans les détails près dans tout ce qui
est vraiment il faut faire très
attention à tout ce qu'on fait et puis
oui ce qui m'attire c'est en fait il y a
une multitude de choses qu'on peut faire
avec la pâtisserie on peut vraiment
aller sur plein de d'horizons différents
et je pense que je pense que c'est
quelque chose qui me plaît est-ce que
vous avez une recette simple à nous à
nous partager d'une pâtisserie que vous
aimez faire
une recette simple je dirais la plus
simple fondant au chocolat on peut pas
on peut pas se tromper ça c'est sûr
la température du four et autant qu'on
met à cuire je pense que c'est important
parce que l'idée justement du fondant au
chocolat c'est qu'à l'intérieur donc il
est tout ce tout se fondant moi
typiquement je l'ai loupe à chaque fois
donc c'est la température faut vraiment
faire attention à la température qu'il
soit pas trop fondante trop dur sur les
extrémités c'est vraiment alors pour
finir est-ce que vous avez un
Instagram qui me suit donc qui suit une
jeune apprentie justement
dessus je partage tout enfin la plupart
de mes TP donc des réalisations qu'on
fait sous soit sous forme de vidéo soit
sous faute de photos et voilà je partage
un petit peu mon quotidien en tant que
pâtissière donc je rappelle c'est @patis
bylena sur sur Instagram merci beaucoup
Lina Méziane d'avoir été avec nous sur
sensation donc je rappelle que vous
représenterez l'Île-de-France au
concours du meilleur croissant au beurre
Destiny Sainte-Mère AOP qui se tiendra
donc les 9 et 10 mai en Normandie et
pour revoir ou réécouter cette émission
rendez-vous sur notre site et notre
application radio sensation
[Musique]